Warning, this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
Um, what just happened?
So yeah, snake rises up, flames come out
and then a
mob of people are
carrying her towards the I
I I mean I don't know about you guys,
but like I've read enough of the Bible
and whatever else of knowledge we have
of what happens in the world that this
is a sacrifice to Satan.
and
everything.
deny that. Yeah, sacrificing a kid
[music] to Bale.
Welcome back everyone to LED Live Light
Exposing Darkness. Today we're going to
talk about Taylor Swift. She's
considered the artist of the decade.
She's currently the biggest pop star out
there. Um, she's doing her Eras Tour
around the world. I think the number one
question we want to see answered today
is
Mikey.
In the Barbie LED Live, you said you
played with Barbies in the past. We were
hoping it I hoped it wouldn't come this
way, but
[laughter]
I did. Um
Are you a Swiftie? Don't ask me that.
Oh, exposed.
I don't know. I never really heard many
of her songs except Shake It Off. Not a
fan of that, so I've never heard any
songs I I feel like I walked I walked
through Walmart so many times hearing
the songs and never knew it was her
until I did the research. I was like,
oh, that's her song. So
even her real name?
What, Swiftie? No, Taylor Swift.
Yeah, yeah, it's actually her It's her
birth name.
name.
Yeah. No, she was born Taylor Swift. So,
Taylor, as I did my research, was
somebody who was always into music and
when she was younger, she even drove out
to Nashville with her mom as a child and
like [music] gave her
like CDs um to different record labels
and was like, I want to be a musician,
sign me. And she got signed at a very
young age and I don't know if you guys
noticed, but she was first considered a
country singer.
I always thought when I remember her
first coming out as more country style.
Yeah, so she was a country singer and
then, you know, eventually kind of
transitioned over to pop and I want to
show you guys a quick video
that shows that she was really
she was considered Miss Americana, which
is like Miss America, basically
Americana. Hometown sweetheart.
that's what it is. So, let's go take a
look.
that with an accent. Hometown
sweetheart.
[laughter]
[music]
Didn't know you could speak Southern.
[laughter]
Girls loved her because she was
relatable, singing about falling in love
and growing up. While parents loved her
innocent [music] image, she encapsulated
the all-American good girl image, backed
up by her flawless interviews showcasing
that American sweetheart from the
countryside persona. [music]
Jay Freedom du Lac wrote in a Washington
Post profile from 2008, she's a
reporter's dream and no doubt a
publicist, too. A media darling indeed.
I live in Tennessee. I am Christian.
Okay, so I just put that last clip in
there just to show you that she says
she's a Christian. And so I I feel like
this is kind of the same thing as, you
know, Miley Cyrus and some of the Disney
They always start out with that squeaky
clean, this is good for my daughter to
listen to and when they watch them over
the years they get more provocative,
more sexual and all that. So, of course
the the fans are going to follow along.
Yeah. And she was considered by the
parents as like, oh, she's just talking
about boys, you know, and teenagers
could relate to her and those kind of
things.
Well, so
I'm interested in I'm When you first
said she was going to Nashville with her
mom, I was going to ask you was there
any history of being a Christian cuz you
know, she's from the South and I just
kind of got that I don't know. I didn't
find that, but I assume if she's a
country singer, most people who are into
country music are also Christians.
What? I guess I assume that's true.
It's true. It's true. Like the deep
South, you know. Maybe. [laughter]
Anyway, so like you said, it's it starts
off kind of like, oh, like like
America's sweetheart and I got a clip
from 2013
um where she performed at the British
Music Awards
and you can kind of see how things
changed a little bit. This is still her
you know, older poppy kind of music,
happy music, but let's take a look at
her performance.
[cheering]
[music]
Okay, I do know that song. Big fan. Not
a
[laughter]
I do recognize the song. The most
annoying thing about her music is it
sticks in your head and I had to listen
to so many of them and I'm just like
She started off with this long white
gown and then flames come up and she's
wearing In front of that door. Did you
see that door? But was Oh, I didn't see
that.
door and it had like this beast head Oh,
I didn't even see that.
like a gargoyle head.
Interesting. And then she's next scene
she's wearing all black and it's all
real skimpy and
I knew you were trouble and it's all
about the school
be like, you know, before I was nice and
[snorts] pure, white
and like dark. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know.
So, I wonder like
Fire. But you were you were pointing
this out. Were you showing this as like
this is a long time ago and it was a
little more tame or is this when she
started kind of
This is when I when you can see she's
starting to dabble a little bit of these
things. So, what I noticed is when she
comes out, white dress, pure white, very
approp well,
appropriately more appropriate.
Uh and there's like white snow falling
and all of a sudden the dancers pull off
her dress and now she's in this very
provocative, sexual kind of outfit doing
sexual dancing. I mean, I was talking to
Kiddy. I said, why is it that most a lot
of these female performers will dress in
clothing that literally would only be
appropriate with your spouse in bed?
Right. You know, like if you're married,
I have no problem you wearing that when
you're married and you're with your
spouse. But this is in front of a lot of
people.
Kids. And there's a lot of
young fans. Like that is really
provocative when you think about it.
This is something you would go buy in
Victoria's Secret for that specific
reason.
Yeah. When you mentioned the snow, it
made me think a little more symbolically
about it. Snow being pure, you know,
washing your sins white as snow and then
all of a sudden there's fire and she's
dancing with fire and all
Yep. Yeah, the attitude changes. She's
like pushing people down.
So, that was 2013.
Now,
um in 2015, she
came out with a song called Bad Blood.
Have you guys heard of this song? Heard
the title.
I don't know. That It's hard to say.
[laughter]
I wasn't a Taylor Swift again. But it
has something in the Walmart
So, there was some kind of an issue
between her and Katy Perry and people
think that most likely this song is
about her confrontation with Katy Perry.
And so this is 2 years later and I want
to take a look at the music video cuz
there seems to be a lot of interesting
symbolism in the music video and again
it's turning more aggressive, more like
confrontational, like, oh, I'm having an
issue with you, I'm going to knock you
down kind of a thing, you know. So,
let's take a look.
Hm. Did you guys pick up on the trinity?
Yeah.
Yep. Everything was white again.
Dressed in black after Same thing. She
starts Her her crew is all in black with
guns and there's fire and everything.
So, she starts off being white, right?
And then she's almost like it's almost
like she's completely vulnerable,
completely I don't know, just white,
pure. Looks like they're going to
program her.
They're like programming her or
something and it's this trinity,
literally it says the trinity
and when I read an interview, this
person's like, oh yeah, it was just me
times three. So, think of it like three
in one, the way God Three in one?
Um and
trinity her or was it still out there?
So, she has a lot of celebrity friends
that were in the video, like almost like
backing her up against this issue with
Katy Perry. That's basically what it
seems like they're doing. Um and so she
then she turns black. So, it's like the
trinity, which obviously in the Bible is
God and Jesus and the Holy Spirit is
like programming her to become evil.
Wow.
And then she walks around and all her
famous celebrity female friends having
weapons
and they gather for a fight and then
they walk with this fire behind them and
you see the final shot where she starts
punching this female, which everybody
thinks is probably representative of
Katy Perry.
I just [snorts] see a trend. Like,
where's the originality? Mhm. It's
always
hey, I'm pure and white and I'm going to
turn bad and
in so many music videos. I mean, it's
ridiculous how many times you see that
theme. Britney Spears Yeah. Beyonce,
whoever.
Uh my take is that, you know, when you
you are artist and then you have signed
a contract for maybe for 5 years, you
know.
And the thing is they they need to tell
you the you know, the big guys is going
to say, hey,
you going to be acting like this, you
need to dress like that, you need to
this is the mission for this year. I
mean, I don't know how is the contract
set, but it seems like in the beginning,
I mean, she was very proud to be, you
know, I'm a Christian, you know, we
don't we don't do this in in my state or
whatever. And now through the years, I
mean I haven't seen the latest because I
don't know who she is, you know,
sometimes you see somebody from
uh posters in Walmart or something like
that, but
[clears throat]
uh
as a Christian, I mean you have
something you see it in your mind like
what is right and what is wrong. Mhm.
And what I got Trinity, everything why I
turn black or something. I mean if a
person grew up a Christian Mhm. and you
see those kind of elements
Mhm. I mean I mean I don't know if the
contract say you need to finish this
contract for 10 years or something or
maybe she just going to be like this is
not how I believe and I'm out.
The
I mean I have we haven't seen seems like
I don't know if it's getting darker or
maybe
I mean I don't know, but
it's going to get darker.
It's only getting worse.
Something that's interesting with that
trend though, you know, our testimonies
are so powerful. The Bible talks about
they overcame with the
word of their testimony and yet our
testimony is like look, this is where I
was. I was in a dark place. I was an
addict. I was this and that and now I've
come out of that. I've walked out of
darkness into the light and yet it's
like Satan is showing here's my
testimony. Here's their testimony. And
over and over and over they're sharing
their testimony. Look, I used to be
white and pure, but now I'm bad Mhm.
that and it's just like that's his way
of putting out everything he does is
reverse of what Yeah.
God created. He's a just perverts
everything that God made. So it's like
he's always putting out his message that
God's the villain. His testimony know
being bad is good. Mhm. That's what I
keep seeing. Mhm. It's amazing you think
about YouTube videos in general. The
most watched ones are music videos.
Mhm. Everything on YouTube, music
videos, always number one. And it's
always your your top pop stars that are
there. This is their their biggest reach
and I'm sure they know that. Mhm. So
it's like this is your your masterpiece
of communication. What are you saying to
the masses, you know?
Mhm.
And I don't know. I mean it's hard to
say. I only saw a little bit, but it's
um it's kind of fascinating if she's
lying there and it almost looks like
she's there's this contrast of
uh the the producer or the industry in
black that's making her like she is,
right? That has put her like on the
table and and it's kind of kind of
stripped everything away from her except
down to like nothing. Mhm. It's like
this is who you are. You're in white.
You have this particular image for the
public, but it's like I want to break
away from that.
Wow.
And I want to be Yep.
you know, I want to be something else.
Cuz she was a good girl before like the
thing portrayed like good girl Taylor
and all of a sudden it's like now,
you know. Yeah. Something different.
of subjective. I mean music videos are a
little bit subjective. It's always hard
to kind of analyze them and say what do
they really mean and Yeah. and all that,
but
yeah, it's it's definitely a platform to
to communicate.
Mhm. You think of all the mothers, you
know, who their daughters are following
somebody like Taylor Swift. What kind of
conversations do they have later or do
they? Yeah. You know, and they're
wondering like why is my daughter
different? Is it because she's kind of
nurtured on the music and the videos and
the image Yep. over time and then it's
like
I'm sure that's only one factor, but it
is a factor.
you know, tell you about Christianity?
She said, "I'm a Christian." You follow
her life and this is where she's at.
Same with Demi Lovato. I got baptized in
the Jordan River. Follow her life, where
she at? She's a
you know, non-binary, communicating with
aliens and then um Beyoncé, same thing.
Yeah, so many people they start out
vocal Christian and then you just oh
cool, I can listen to them cuz they're
Christian and then you follow their life
and they're just going down this dark
hole. It seems like it's like a spell.
Mhm. I mean I mean they start like as a
Christian like a good girl like I want
to be famous, but then later on the
entertainment industry is just burning
like a black hole. Wow. You got to make
a choice. Do you want money or do you
want Jesus?
Mhm. Mhm. Yep. Yeah.
It's hard to do both. You know, the
Bible says that you can't serve God and
mammon. Mhm. So which one are you going
to serve? I think God on purpose only
chooses
a very few people to have a lot of
wealth. Mhm. Because I think he knows it
would corrupt.
The love of money is the root of all
evil, the Bible says. It would corrupt a
lot of people.
And what kind of people would we be?
Plus we're not as dependent on God.
Yeah. Right? Yeah. We don't we don't
learn to trust him because like well,
why would I why would I trust God? I
have everything I need. Which is
interestingly enough the description of
the Laodicean church. Mhm. Right? In the
end of the end of the Bible in
Revelation chapter 3. They're rich
increased in goods and have need of
nothing.
Wow.
So they have no dependence on God.
It's a description of our times.
So after this confrontation with Katy
Perry, um there was another issue she
had with some celebrities, which is
Kanye West and Kim Kardashian.
I won't go into the whole what went on
about that, but basically as a result of
that, a lot of her fans called Swifties
ended up um posting on her social media
a snake emoji calling her a snake. Like
you can see her Instagram and it's just
like loads of snake snake snake snakes.
So they're hating on her.
They're hating on her now. They're
turning their back on her.
are The fans, I guess and also not
people are not fans, but like fans among
them calling her a narcissist and that
resulted in her taking a one-year
hiatus, which is 2016 to 2017.
Um so this earlier news um clip that we
saw, they kind of talk about that as
well. Her documentary Miss Americana,
she admits she focused on being nice to
sell country music. Her success [music]
depended on being liked for being an
image of herself. It took a toll on
Taylor mentally. She felt her success
[music] wasn't deserved. Having her
self-worth tied up with being liked came
to be a nightmare with the famous fiasco
with Kim Kardashian and Kanye [music]
West. It all came down at once. Her
every move was seen as calculated from
her once positively viewed girl squad of
famous female friends to her
relationships. [music]
Her good girl image was gone as social
media collectively labeled her a snake.
[music] People were vocally announcing
their dislike for Taylor Swift and it
was straining her. She said in her
movie, "I had to deconstruct an entire
belief system for my own personal
sanity." She took a step back from the
spotlight to find herself [music] in her
darkest days. Her new album Reputation,
please welcome Taylor Swift. Taylor
Swift eventually came back to the
spotlight with the release of
Reputation. She reinvented herself fully
embracing her role as a villain. As the
public saw her as a narcissist, she used
it as fuel for her music. She was no
longer hiding behind her good girl image
and is finding who she is as a woman. As
she said to herself, "The old is dead
and the new Taylor no longer cares about
the public's perception of her." Wow.
There's a lot of like spiritual things
in there like Yeah.
the old Taylor is dead. We're supposed
to die, but she's embracing the villain.
The snake. Embracing the snake.
Yep. Yep. So I want to look at the Bible
verse that talks about what a snake
represents, right? Revelation 12:9, "So
the great dragon was cast out, that
serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world. He
was cast to the earth and his angels
were cast out with him." Now I want to
make a statement here. A lot of people
watching this will probably say, "Why
are you comparing it to the devil?" Like
clearly people were just calling her a
snake and she's like, "Mhm, I'm just
going to run with it."
But as we keep going in this episode,
you will see like yes, that's true.
There's that side of the story, but then
there's also a lot of
um you know, satanic imagery that we
keep seeing over and over and over again
in her videos that it's kind of like a
two-edged sword in what she's doing. Um
let's look at this next clip. Uh like
the music the news
clip said she start embracing herself as
a villain. She came out with this new
album called Reputation. And there's a
particular song that she put out called
What You Made Me Do, which people think
is probably talking about Kanye West and
Kim Kardashian. Again, some interesting
stuff in this particular video.
[music]
Damn, you remember one of the movie
posters for um
what's that series?
Uh The Hunger Games. Yeah.
It had uh
Red. Katniss in a red Yeah. red outfit
on a white throne. So what does it mean
biblically speaking when they put
someone in a red outfit on a throne?
Well, a throne is dominion, right? So
it's and especially like a white throne
with white meaning purity.
Yep. Um the only woman that you really
find wearing red in in Bible is
the woman that's in Revelation that's
the Sitting down on the
beach, right?
um
she's the
essentially a prostitute. Mhm. Yeah.
She's the woman who's not the pure
church. Right. Scarlet Harlot.
Yeah, the Scarlet Harlot.
Mhm. And she's she's the one in the in
Revelation, she's the one manipulating
all the nations to
um
essentially, you know, succumb to her
will
from a religious perspective cuz a woman
in in Revelation prophecy is a church.
Yeah. So, if that's a Revelation scarlet
representing sin, a scarlet church or a
corrupt church and then she's a
representation of that sitting on a
throne. I mean, that's pretty symbolic
showing
Yeah. It's like the Antichrist taking
the throne.
I think
cuz you have to be you have to take
symbols in context.
So, it's not that the color red is is
inherently evil or anything like that,
right? It's just in the context, you
know, it talks about the woman being
drunk with the blood of the saints, you
know.
Um and we also see red or at least
crimson red in in other parts of the
Bible, right?
Isaiah, wash me and I'll be whiter than
snow. Right. And and so, [clears throat]
red, you know, is is representative of
blood. But when you have a character
that's like dressed in red and it says,
you know, they've that they have
um you know, drunk with the blood of the
saints, then it's like it's it's like a
badge of honor versus, you know, we're
told to wash our robes with the blood of
the lamb. in the blood of the lamb, but
they come out
white. That's right. So, it's not like
red is, you know, he is like if it's if
it's, you know, Jesus, red is is his
blood, which is cleansing, which is
awesome.
Yeah.
You know, but for the woman, it's
identifying blood from a a different
perspective, right? She's
she's
uh reveling in the fact that she has
been responsible for the death of many
millions. But again, being told
completely different because she went
from white to the red to black. Mhm.
Interesting. There's a progression
there.
And I find it interesting, too, that she
says in the documentary
Miss Americana that she's a Christian.
That was pretty recent. That's a Netflix
It's a Netflix documentary. Yeah. So,
recently she's like, "I'm a Christian."
But then
she's putting herself into this biblical
imagery of the apostate church,
basically. It's it's probably
you know, if you think about that it's
Of course, there's a lot of people that
identify as Christian, but you have to
think of what does the world think a
Christian is?
You know, it's not, you know, how often
is You think of somebody like that, her
life is completely scheduled. Yeah.
Right? How much time do you think that
she has
of her own? Right. Now, she has probably
a manager who's like, "Okay, you're
going to get up at this time and we have
this appointment here and this
appointment here. We're going to get
lunch on the road or get it from this
restaurant. You got to make this
appointment and you got to have your
exercise routine so you can keep in
shape and, you know,
do your thing on stage and all that."
And we've got And it's probably just
seriously one thing after another. Do
you think she has time to read her
Bible? Mhm.
And discover like
what a Christian is. And you think,
"Well, maybe she knows when she's
growing up."
Maybe maybe not. I mean, we don't know.
Yeah. What's her religious upbringing?
Is it kind of the generic like, "Yeah,
just, you know, believe in Jesus." And
Go to church Easter and Christmas. Yeah.
What it What does it mean like I'm a
Christian? I think it depends on who you
talk to. Mhm. I think that's Satan's
main attack, too, is distraction. I
mean,
so many people have Bibles in their
homes and they don't read them and it's
because, oh, Facebook, oh, the video
game, oh, whatever the distraction is.
And with her,
she has no life, no time to spend that
time with God.
And he's constantly pursuing her
and she's just constantly distracted and
busy. Yeah, that's really sad cuz God
loves her. Like, I do want to make that
statement. Like, we don't we don't make
these videos to like bash on people.
We're making these videos because we do
believe we need to expose the darkness,
but the darkness of the devil and he
uses people for that. But God loves
Taylor Swift. He wants her to be saved
and we want to see her saved as well.
And use her platform to reach millions.
Right. With her voice, she can do
amazing [clears throat] things for the
Lord. Yeah.
Let me show you guys this screenshot
real quick. I just flashed through this,
but there was she was sitting on a
swing. Yeah, she has a snake tattoo as
well.
She's wearing the rings with the snakes
on it. Necklace, snakes are like serving
her tea and And the fact that she's
wearing red sitting on a throne with
snakes all around her. I mean, the
symbology is Did you see what the the
throne said though on there? No, what
did it say? It had Latin. Et tu, Brute.
Oh, yes. Um It comes from Shakespeare.
Shakespeare. Mhm. Um Julius Caesar says
that because he's going to the market
and this is the day that he is murdered.
Mhm. Okay? So, he he cries out because
Mark Antony is involved in the
conspiracy to kill him because Mark
Antony is involved with Cleopatra,
right? And so, he gets killed
at the marketplace and the so he says
this, "Et tu, Brute. Then die, Caesar."
Like and it means even you
um Brutus. Brutus.
Yeah. Yeah. So, then die, Caesar. And
so, he's like
he's kind of accepting his his fate and
death at that point because everybody
has turned on him. Mhm. Fitting with the
whole theme of her dying, being in the
grave.
it's like everybody's turned on me. Mhm.
So, then die, Caesar. Wow. Um
yeah, [clears throat] really really
subtle. Yeah. It's there. Yeah, so
subtle, but so deep, which just shows
you that there's a lot of thought put
into all this stuff. Yeah. I did notice
[clears throat] the
uh unlucky occult number 13 written huge
on there.
Yeah, she says it's her lucky number,
but actually in occultism, I think on
the on the tarot card, which tarot cards
are used for like magic and satanic
occult stuff, divination.
Uh number 13 also represents death. Mhm.
And she says it's her lucky number.
She's in a birdcage. Yeah.
Yeah, she ooh. Mhm. What does that mean?
Occult. She's trapped. Yeah. Yeah. You
know, she's a spectacle. Everybody's
looking in on what she's doing.
Yeah. Yeah. So, it's interesting to see
that she's publicly making the statement
of I've died to my old self. You see
also at the like the final shot, there's
a big T and she's standing at the top
like the new Taylor Swift and all the
old Taylors, they're those are all
Taylors from old music videos in
particular clothing. They're all trying
like crawl up to her and she kicks them
away and she's and then she has the
phone call with the snake ring saying
like the old Taylor's dead. Mhm. So, the
reason I looked that music video up is
because
I was I was looking at some trailers for
movies and TV shows that were coming out
recently and there's this one show
that's put out by Amazon Prime
and it's called Wilderness.
Okay?
And that show uses that song as the
intro Mhm. for the whole series. I'm
like, "That's kind of interesting."
Especially when you're you're listening
to the words, right? So,
the quick synopsis of this is a drama,
it's a thriller. It says follows a
twisted love story where the happily
ever after life quickly turns into a
living nightmare. Oh, wow.
And so, that's the song they're using
for that.
Um
that show. So, anytime you have a piece
of music that's put on the beginning of
the show, it's very representative of
Yeah. what the show is like. Yeah,
they're not just going to pick something
out of the hat. It was very like
vengeful. Yep. You know, all the scenes
were like very, you know, very vengeful,
very
what the song is about, yeah, about
taking vengeance. Sounds like a vibe.
That's true. And so, I was like, "I
wonder if the song is kind of
like that." And I looked at the music
video and I was like, "Yep, it
definitely is." Yeah.
So, I'm going to show you guys um
when she performs this song live, what
this looks like. Oh, interesting. So, we
have these images flash by, her posing
in a white dress, right? And then there
were images flashing by where she was
sitting on a throne with these satanic
devil-like beings all around her.
[snorts]
Um we see snakes everywhere and she's
like having this massive snake come over
her. I mean, that's pretty dark stuff.
Yeah, I guess. That's what you expect
from a teenage pop, you know, somebody
that started out that way, you know.
Yeah. Except to me, it's like
those people that go to this kind of
concert
and
I mean, like you were saying, it's
getting darker and darker. Mhm. I mean,
what is the effect
of
uh
I guess we can talk about music, but
it's something like, you know,
uh they started maybe just like a all
nice country music or, you know,
sounds very nice, a little 13-year-old
cute music, you know, "That I love about
this boy."
to this. Yeah.
I mean, how will affect in the
making decisions or how they act in
their life and
to white to dark? It's just interesting
though, the simple observations you can
make about the way society behaves.
Right?
Why is it that you don't have
lots of children running around at night
or parents feel uncomfortable with that?
Well, for one, most people are in bed.
But why wouldn't you want your teenagers
out late at night? Cuz they're only
getting into trouble at that point.
They're only getting into trouble,
right? Why is it that it seems like more
trouble happens at night?
Mhm, you're doing things under the
shadows and Mhm. can't be seen, right?
Bible talks about that simple principle
that all things are manifest, made
manifest by the light.
Mhm.
Right? It's like why don't you go and
just like hang out at the cemetery at
night?
I mean That's creepy.
It just doesn't it? Why? Why is it
creepy though?
Cuz it's dark. Cuz it's dark. I don't
want to go there. I mean but it's not
any darker at the cemetery than anywhere
else at night, right? Yeah, right.
But it it's it is interesting how we
won't go places or do certain things
because we we think well it's it's dark
there.
Yeah. Right? And then little kids
they they fear or they develop a fear.
You don't even have to tell them. They
develop a fear for the dark. Why?
Yeah.
I remember when my kids first started
talking about monsters. I was like what
in the world is a monster? Like what is
a monster? I asked them cuz I'd never
seen a monster. Like what are you
talking about? A monster. What does that
mean? They're like it's a really scary
guy.
Right? [clears throat]
Why why are kids
why are they scared of the dark? Why do
they get scared of the dark? I know why
I was scared of the dark as a kid. Mhm.
Why? Just cuz it's the unknown. You
can't tell like something something
right in front of me I can't see it or
Yeah, and so
what kind of influence does it have?
Um so this was a 2018 studio tour. Now
remember the song Bad Blood? She
performed that at this tour as well. So
let's go take a look.
[music]
Okay, so she's clearly again wearing an
outfit that is really inappropriate to
wear in public that I think you should
only wear in the bedroom with your
spouse with your husband.
And then she's wearing that on this
like snake-like figurine
almost like a snake skeleton. It makes
me think of in the past in the Bible
where they put up shrines and it was
always high up, right? And everybody
would be coming to worship the shrine
and everybody's there surrounding her
looking up at Taylor Swift in this
Raising their hands.
in this symbol that is in the Bible is
symbolic of Satan. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
You look around at cultures all around
the world and you see Mayan snakes and
China dragon and it's really happening
in here even in good old Christian
America
people are filling stadiums raising
their hands to a snake. Yeah,
worshipping her cuz that's what they do.
They worship these people. Call them
idols for a reason. American Idol. Yeah.
So there's another video she put out
that says
are you ready for it? And I have cut
this music video up in multiple parts
because there's so much
interesting stuff happening in this
video, interesting symbolism. So let's
take a look.
[music]
Wow.
guys see that?
So
a parasite? It's a snake. So she looks
like an Android and a
witch [snorts] version of herself is
meeting and then this red flash. I mean
it's all every every video is like black
dressed in black, red flames or
something and snakes.
So she approaches she comes out of this
like graffiti like um alley
and there's all these like weird
alien-like creatures around her like
robotic alien creatures. And so she
approaches this other version of her
that is in this box again
and she is the darker hooded black and
red Taylor and across from her is this
white pure Taylor again with
like there's not even any clothing on
her, right? She's just covered with like
a white nothing.
said stripped down in a isolated like
cage or something.
Yep. And then as she approaches her it's
like her the hooded Taylor has like it
flashes back and forth between what she
sees across from her, the white pure
Taylor and the hooded Taylor.
that's on the outside. Yeah, and so the
and then as these images flash back and
forth only on the white pure Taylor does
a snake crawl up her face. Right? Which
is supposed to be pure but then there's
a snake crawling across her face.
Now she's being corrupted.
Right, interesting, huh?
Let's look
That's what's really inside.
That's what I was thinking. Yeah.
The real me is coming out.
Let's take a look at part two of this
clip.
[music]
What do you guys think of that? White
horse? Yeah. Revelation?
[music]
I don't know. Are they going to battle
each other or something? No, no, that's
the thing. They're encountering each
other but we'll see in a later clip
they're going to become one.
Oh, Yin and Yang. Yes. The balance of
good and evil.
Yes. [snorts]
And so what's interesting it looks like
this white Taylor is like the pure
Taylor uncorrupted but then she sort of
like transforms into this black dark
Taylor and has like a weapon or
something and then she becomes a white
horse. It's like she's going back and
forth between good and evil. And the
other this side of the fence is the dark
Taylor that's just evil the whole time.
They're both kind of gravitating towards
the wicked right now with the snake and
everything. Yeah, cuz remember the white
Taylor had the snake crawling across her
face. So yeah.
[music]
So it seems like what's happening is
that
you know, they put their hands together
as if they're becoming one but then
again the dark Taylor is getting
destroyed by the white pure Taylor but
the white and pure Taylor Taylor started
becoming dark herself
Yeah. and had the snake. So it's almost
to me I'm wondering if this is kind of
her telling her story of
you know, putting away the old self and
and accepting that symbol of the snake
but again she's doing away with that
purity and becoming that dark force and
just embracing it. And breaking out of
the glass thing. out of the glass house.
It's always about you know, this is the
Gnostic thing too about
breaking out of the garden, the perfect
world. And embracing that outer
darkness, you know. That's so
interesting.
There's a lot of celebrities that have
been you know, done music videos where
they're like caged and stuff.
It's not a new thing. Oh yeah, yeah.
It's all this stuff keeps getting
repeated which makes one question. You
you know, it's not like we're just like
over analyzing something. When you see
something over and over and over and
over again you should start to ask
questions like why? What is this what's
the pattern? When you see a pattern it's
not just coincidence every time. That's
ridiculous to even think that. So the
question is who's in the box? The white
or the black one? The white was in the
box but she broke out. So the black one
has like a freedom. No, it's about the
way you well,
it's about the way you look at it. So
the white one in the box
is the one that is like the world is
seeing. Everybody's looking in.
Right? So everybody's
on the outside is looking at this
spectacle. So actually it's lifted up.
You should see me in my dreams, right?
So everybody's looking in but the true
self
is on the outside.
It's what everybody's not seeing.
And it's yeah, different forms like in
the bird cage and in the the glass thing
and what was she in something else too
but
yeah.
You see that a lot.
So I want to point something else out to
you guys.
Did you guys see the like electricity or
thunder or something?
I mean I'm not saying that's for sure
what this is. I just want to point out
it does say in the Bible and he said to
them, I saw Satan falling like lightning
from heaven. Luke 10:18. Um so here's
the writing on the
thing. They're burning all the witches.
Yep. They're burning all the witches
well. Um which is interesting later on
we're going to look a little bit into
because she's going to burn? They're
burning all the witches. It's all
fascinating.
Salem witch trial thing like that is
that's the secular world's way of
knocking Christianity. Like oh, you
like, the witch and all that stuff.
Anybody that's, you know, doing their
own thing, you just think is evil.
It's the way it was done. It's It's And
And really
that was a dumb
moment for Christianity in that
it was not the Christians'
responsibility to burn the witches,
right? Just like it's not anybody else's
responsibility to burn the martyrs.
Right? That's something that humanity
takes upon itself.
But It's And it's And it's all the way
they did it, you know? It's like,
especially like throwing them in the
water and stuff. Do you remember that?
If you swim, you're a witch. If you can
swim. Yeah, and if you drown, you
weren't.
Yeah, so oh, it's So she died in
drowning, so Of course. I mean, it just
It points out the, you know, really
people's stupidity. Unfortunately,
Christianity gets attached to that.
And it's not something that the
Christians of that time should have
taken upon themselves.
You know, they should have done Not that
they should have been accepting of
witches. I'm not saying that. There was
a better way to handle it. And that's
the problem. Christianity takes the rap
for the way it was handled. I get it. It
was handled poorly. But it doesn't mean
that witches are good.
Yeah. Right. That's At the end of the
day, it doesn't mean witchcraft's okay
because Christianity handled it poorly
during that time.
Yeah. God is still clearly against
witchcraft. So, [snorts] we're going to
go into the witchcraft thing a little
bit more later and her associations with
witchcraft, but I want to show you guys
a performance she did at the 2018
American Music Awards. And when I saw
this, I like literally threw my
headphones off, and I was like, "What is
this?"
Uh which I think everybody heard.
Yep, I heard you. Um yeah.
I was [laughter] like in shock. So,
let's take a look.
[music]
Um What just happened?
So, a snake rises up, flames come out,
and then a
mob of people are
carrying her towards the I mean
I mean I don't know about you guys, but
like I've read enough of the Bible and
whatever else of knowledge we have of
what happens in the world that this is a
sacrifice to Satan. Yeah, the flames and
everything and the
that. Yeah, it's sacrificing the kids to
Moloch And she's saying, "Light me up."
Mhm. So, what are they What is she
Give her to Moloch or the snake?
I mean, this happened in the Bible where
in
Bale worshipers, which was a false god,
literally would burn people in front of
their god. Light me up, and there's
fire, and there's a snake, and she's
lying down like she's being sacrificed.
It was a huge abomination to God when
he's listing off different things that
he's displeased with. Um you know, one
of them in particular is King Manasseh.
You know, it says that he even made his
children walk through the fire, you
know, that kind of thing.
Um which is this this idea of child
sacrifice, too. And the Bible's against
that. Very against that.
Yeah.
Wow. Yeah, this just gives me the
creeps, man. Like
But then they they put in the nice cool
beat. Yeah. And then this like, hey,
don't worry about it. Just just you need
to be a spell right here. You need to be
just
Oh.
Glad you brought that up cuz this is
just side note, but there's something
going around now like mainstream news
articles are covering it
that
people that go to these concerts,
Beyoncé, too, I think. Beyoncé and
Taylor Swift are having post
uh concert amnesia.
They're leaving the concert, and whole
groups of people are like, "I don't even
remember what I was doing here." Yeah.
They can't even remember what they just
saw.
I did look into it. It does say
[laughter]
It does say there's scientific
I've been to a lot of concerts, man.
I've banged my head in mosh pit and I
remember everything. I was drinking at
those places. I don't I've never heard
this before until recently.
Like, why is it coming out now? They
might have some kind of science to back
it up, but why all these years of
concerts, I've never heard that I went
to this concert, I don't remember any of
it. Yeah.
Do you remember that clip that we used
to use thing or documentaries uh or
seminars that
Dane Cook found that went to
lots of people that go to the movie
theater, and they were playing those
those scenes, you know, and flashing and
everything, and
weirder stuff, and they watched the
whole thing, and he's after the show,
and he's asking people like, "Hey, can
you tell us about what is What is about
this movie? What movie you were
watching? What is it The movie's called
this, but what is about?" Was it
Inception or Was it something else?
know. It was something else, but
I
The The people's like, "Um the movie's
about Yeah, about
uh and the I mean, it's
it sounds and looks
I mean, very dumb how they answer it.
And they're like, "Oh, and then I mean
like they were so hypnotized, and
they're like they couldn't I mean,
seriously, they couldn't answer. To me,
it was kind of like funny, right? Like,
"Oh my goodness, look at this guy. Can I
Why I mean, couldn't remember."
to me more than once.
I remember leaving a theater and saying,
"Man, that was awesome." And I'm like, I
can't even really remember what the
story was about or what scenes were
awesome, but I know it was awesome. I
don't think that's ever happened to me.
I remember every single thing. I mean,
I'm that kind of guy.
Well, and I should say, it's not like
people saying they forget the whole
concert. It's sections of it. So, I
mean, it's a good It's a good debate
that people, if you want to, can have in
the comment section. Is it scientific?
Is it some kind of a spell that people
are talking about? I mean, it It makes
dress as fun like it's not the whole
concert. Come on.
[laughter]
It's not the whole concert. They just
The whole crowd just forgot one part of
it.
[laughter]
Why? Is what I want to know. No, the
frequency. I'm sure you guys heard about
this frequency, how Yeah, Justin Bieber
using stuff. the music frequency, and
people's reaction is like more violence
to it. That's true. Red Hot Chili
Peppers, they would like set fires in
the in the in in the crowd and destroy
things and stuff.
Let's take a look at the lyrics of what
she's actually singing.
So, the song is called I Did Something
Bad, and she said, "They say I did
something bad, then why why does it feel
so good? They say I did something bad,
but why does it feel so good? Most fun I
ever had, and I just do it over and over
again if I could. It just felt so good
good."
I mean, I don't have kids yet. I'm
getting married in 2 weeks. Not planning
on having kids for 2 years. Not going to
have teenagers for quite a while. But I
would never want my kids to listen to
this and learn, "Oh, it doesn't matter.
Just do whatever you want." I mean,
that's the philosophy of Aleister
Crowley, who was considered the beast.
Like, he was a Satan worshiper,
occultist, who was the most
you know, did the most despicable things
you can probably imagine, and he wrote,
"Do what thou wilt shall be the whole of
the law," directly attacking God's 10
Commandments. That's basically what she
is singing in her song. Do whatever you
want. Feels good. It don't matter if
it's bad. And it's even saying there
They say I did something bad. So, when
the pastor, when your parents, they say
it's bad, but it feels so good. I'm just
going to do it over and over and over.
Yeah. What kind of message is that
sending? Yeah, that's the basis for
moral relativism,
which
is a scourge on society.
So, that was a 2018 studio tour, and she
just finished the US portion of her
current Eras Tour.
And she's going overseas, so she's still
touring all around the world, and then
she's going to do a few more concerts in
the US later on. So, I'm thinking like,
"Hmm, what about her current tour and
her current performances? What do those
look like?" Yeah, so there's like a
snake There's snakes everywhere. There's
a snake following her across the stage,
snakes biting them, and um she has
microphones with a snake on it on her
hand, and yeah. And her her outfit in
this performance is like red and black,
and also has snakes all across it. I
just wonder about
these people's parents, you know? Like,
Katy Perry, her dad's a pastor. She's
going down the same road.
Uh
you know, Taylor Swift, I always just
wonder what her mom thinks, you know?
Her mom
parents support her. Oh my goodness.
Yeah. They go They go along on tour with
her and are there for her and You know
why?
I [clears throat] don't know. Because
it's just entertainment. What? That's
what they think. It's just I mean, it's
just put that I mean, they are proud of
their daughter.
You know, everybody's happy. Taylor,
what about This one I know Victoria's
Secret doing any evil [laughter] things,
you know? I mean, they just you know, I
I thought about that. Like, if you were
like
Everything's good. Like, if you saw Zoey
growing up, and all of a sudden she
started dressing like that, and you
know, start performing like that, I
mean, I think you'd have a hard time
with it.
Yeah. Yeah. She already has a hard time
with my conditions.
Yeah.
So, this was the snake bit of her
performance. Uh there was something else
that was a little bit controversial that
she was doing at her performances, which
is witchcraft. Uh so, we're going back
to the witchcraft bit.
Let's take a look. Cherry top of the
cake. In her most [music] recent
concert, Taylor Swift is performing
witchcraft. And I know this is going to
raise some controversy [music] in the
comments, but this just doesn't look
right to me.
[music]
[singing]
I come back STRONGER THAN A
[screaming]
HEY, DANCE, [__] YES. HEY.
HEY.
YES. SUMMON THE DEMONS.
YES.
MOTHER WANTS US TO MAKE it official, so
let's do it. As you might know, she left
those comments on this video.
And this part right here is the one that
we are making a new official Willow
chant. And I need your help, you guys.
She has a whole witch dance break during
Willow at the Eras Tour.
When she says, "I come back stronger
than a 90s trend," immediately scream,
"Summon the demons When you go to a
show,
do this with your friends. After the
show, upload the video on TikTok, tag
Taylor, tag your friends, tag me, and
I'm going to be going through tags
of you doing the Willow chant, Igor's
version. So, she wants them to do that,
or how did this start?
No. But it's it's it's very telling of
Yeah.
Clearly, people can see what this looks
like. Mhm.
It's not just some religious zealots
like us. Mhm. Yeah.
No offense to us. But you see how they
package all this too, like it's like
Mhm. So, Disney does it, too. We got a
video called Candy Coated Witchcraft,
where you know, Elsa's doing blatant
witchcraft, but it's all packaged in
this pretty music, Disney little bow on
it.
Yep. And yeah, that's what lets people's
guards down.
He He's someone who went to the concert,
and he posted that video on TikTok where
he says, "Summon the demon B."
Mhm. And I guess he posted that, and
Taylor Swift was like she said, "Is this
the new 1 2 3
B, honest
B, you know, the cuss word. So, she
actually saw it.
She saw it, and she commented on it, and
she basically, I think what she's saying
is, "Is this the new 1 2 3?" Like it's
the new thing. Mhm. And then the guy,
Igor, responds, and he's like, "Well,
everybody, whenever you go to the
concerts, when we get to this line in
the song, say, 'Summon the demons
B,' you know,
and and people were commenting like,
"Yeah, I'm going to do that," and those
kind of things, and Wow, dude.
Yeah. And and like you said, it's like
people know what she's doing. And even
though that dude's not a Christian, he's
picking up on there's something's more
deeper going on, but he's joking about
it.
And now you're going to have
[clears throat] a a crowd full of people
saying, "Summon the demons."
Yep. I mean, that What What do you think
you're telling the spirit world when
you're in a crowd full of people in a
crowd full of people are summoning the
demons, and you got people doing a
ritual on stage, like
Mhm.
Well, and then in the beginning, too,
what did Taylor say, like, "Wait for the
signal, and they'll meet you after"?
Like,
who was she referring to? Yeah.
She's talking about demons, man. Wow.
Yeah,
we
In those kind of concerts, man, I mean,
you invoking
and burning, you know,
I mean, something's going to be
appearing. Something's going to be crazy
stuff over there, possessions, you know.
Yeah.
Music is a is
is praise. It's worship. You We're
supposed to sing it to God. And when
you're in here singing about summoning
demons, as opposed, it makes sense that
if you didn't want any associations that
way, that you would completely avoid it
at all costs. Mhm.
Mhm. Change your imagery.
Yep.
Yeah. Right. If you don't If you don't
If you don't If you're not doing that,
and you don't want people to get the
wrong idea,
it's very easy. Mhm. Right? You just You
don't do that.
Yep. Mhm. And then it You know, it's
like the Bible says, "Avoid the
appearance of evil."
But what about What about people that
say, "Oh, they're just doing it cuz it's
controversial, and it gets the
attention." And And actually, what we're
doing is giving her more attention and
all that. You know, I I was obsessed
with Marilyn Manson growing up, and my
parents were like, "Man, this guy is
evil, and the stuff he's doing." And I'm
like, "It's shock value." I used to blow
it It's shock value.
But who cares if it's shock value? If
I'm ripping up a Bible
just to get a shock value, I'm still
ripping up a Bible.
That's right. That's true. I mean, the
act is still being done, and and you're
entertaining people with that. If you're
chanting, "Summon the demons," and
you're just doing it because it's fun or
whatever, you're still saying, "Summon
the demons." I mean,
it's wild, man. Yeah.
Yeah, I just You know, if you don't If
you don't want the association, just
avoid it altogether. Bible says, "By
your words, you'll be justified, and by
your words, you'll be condemned." That's
right. So, think about your words. Yeah.
Mhm.
So, the song she's performing here is
Willow, and the reason why she's
performing witchcraft on stage is
because it also appears in her music
video, which is strange because the
lyrics have nothing to do with
witchcraft, but she puts witchcraft in
the music video itself.
[music]
Well, again, like you said,
this is just being packaged in this Like
you wouldn't expect it. Listen to the
song, you're thinking whatever.
No.
Teen pop, and then you see the video.
And that's the way Lady Gaga did, too,
cuz
if you look at Lady Gaga's music videos,
it looks very much like what Marilyn
Manson looked like. But when you hear it
in the store, it's just like
You would not expect that imagery to go
with it. Yeah.
So, they
It's It's all about It's a psychological
thing to make you let your guard down.
Like, "Oh, there's nothing wrong with
this. This feel You know, it's fun.
Yeah.
Feels good. Yeah, you go to the concert,
and you're snake sacrifice.
So, we're all Christians. Mhm. I do this
every night. I run in the woods and go
dancing with witches. Normal day
[snorts] in the in the woods.
No. Yeah, your average day in the woods.
Take some friends out there and summon
some fireballs.
I know, right? It's like, "Uh, I don't
think this has anything to do with
Christianity or the Bible."
Yeah, I'm when I went camping with my
friends and some
club in the church,
uh we got lost one time.
And that part of
place in where live in Chiapas, South
Mexico.
Uh that place it was known as
the
the witches' town.
And we found out that evening, and we
knew about that small island
that we were camping. And that town, it
was all the witches in all of the people
there.
And but it's beautiful spot to go
camping, you know. So, we were camping
that weekend. And that evening, I'm not
kidding you, you can tell me like, "Nah,
that thing is not real." No, I saw that.
You When are you hear silence in the
woods,
it's not very fun.
And do you see
flying
balls of fire. Oh, you saw that?
Yeah. Ooh, that's creepy.
crazy. Let me tell you, it's 11 more
people witnessed
It's not the only person. And let me
tell you, I talked to my friend. I
haven't talked to him for like 25 years.
And he's not a Christian anymore
everything. We had a conversation, "Hey,
man, how's life doing?" And and I have
this episode, and I said, "Do you
remember when we got lost in the woods?"
And they're like, "Bro, I don't want to
talk about that. I don't want to talk
about that." And then they said, "Yeah,
and do you remember those fire woods?"
"Yes, I remember that."
Mhm. And they said, "That's the only
thing that can say is
it's a good and evil. You know, I don't
go to church anymore, you know, but I
remember that that God protected us from
that. That's the only thing I can say
that God protected us that evening. And
both nights that we were there, you see
like Don't think it was like some guy
with a flashlight in the woods or
something like that. No, that was It was
like this kind of
I'm not kidding you, like
flying over there, and flying things,
and it goes off, and then goes on, and
flying around. Yeah.
And they were And we found out later on,
they said, "Why Why did these things
happen?" They said, "No, they're they're
witches." And and uh
Um yeah, all the things that they're
practicing, they're doing this stuff.
They convert to fire, you know, all this
stuff. I mean, who knows if it's true or
not.
all that. Yeah. Yeah. So, wait, I I saw
that. Yeah. I saw that maybe happened
like maybe eight to 10 times. And we
were like, "You know what? You're in
inside the tent."
And the little window's like, you know,
this much for 12 people. Like, "Let me
see. Let me see." And "Wait, wait,
wait." And when you see those
weird thing. Mhm. And we're like, "We're
never going to come back this place."
Mhm.
[laughter]
Seriously.
Yeah. I I went on a mission trip to
Iceland years ago, and
in the capital Reykjavik, there's this
really famous big church.
And they had like
a garden around it with just a bunch of
statues. And they were supposed to be
Christian statues.
But they were like full-on
demonic-looking, like freaking
scary-looking.
And a group of
part of a group had gone the previous
day cuz they were doing a prayer walk
and they were like there's something
about that garden, like it's really
weird, dark, heavy. And I was a little
skeptical. I was like
I don't know. And so the next day the
whole group was there and I was there,
too.
And I kid you not, like there was a
step, as soon as I put my foot on that
step, it was like gravity was pushing me
down. Like I felt a physical weight just
pushing me down into the ground. And I
was kind of like
yeah, whatever, you know, still a little
bit like that and I start walking out
and I heard this voice that's like
stay with everybody else. Don't go off
on your own. I'm like
why? Like God will protect me. Like it's
just statues, you know? And I took a
couple steps and it just came worse and
I was like
okay, I have to listen and I listened to
the Holy Spirit speaking to me like do
not do that and I stayed with the group.
As soon as I stepped out of the garden,
the pressure was lifted. I've never
experienced anything like that. It's not
like you feel a little like depressed or
dark. It was a physical
like pressure that pushed me down. And
so like this stuff is real, you know?
There's a real battle between good and
evil.
And when these celebrities start
portraying these kind of images in their
music videos, we can't joke around with
that. Like like this is
from the devil and he has a clear
message to tell the world. That was
happening at the um
Travis, I can't remember his name now,
but the Astroworld concert.
And
there was people all these TikTok videos
came out and they were like, I'm not
even Christian or anything, but I
remember looking at my boyfriend being
like, this is demonic. And everybody
said it was such a creepy
vibe that whole night and everything and
and that's when people were dying in the
crowd and stuff.
As a Christian, we know that prayer is
so powerful.
Even though
I mean, they look kind of dark and all
that evil stuff.
[snorts]
Prayer is so powerful. But let me tell
you those people over there, their
experience
in those concerts and they're singing
those kind of songs and they're doing
all those rituals and they're saying
calling demon name or whatever they're
doing.
Uh
how your life is going to be after the
concert?
Transforming. How we believe as a
Christian, you know, what? I'm going to
pray over you. I believe in the name of
Jesus going to be changing your life,
healing or transforming and deliverance
and all the stuff.
When you experience those things in
concerts or anything
your life is going to change. I think
you're opening a door. When you choose,
you buy a ticket, you plan, you go, you
take the work day off or whatever.
You're you're open It's not like you got
kidnapped and taken there. You were
willfully going to this place.
And you're telling the spirit world, I'm
giving you permission to my life in one
way or another. That's a warning to any
Christian that wants to go to Taylor
Swift concert or any other one like
that.
So she actually tweeted about this back
in the day when Twitter was still
Twitter.
Um well, she tweeted about her song
Willow. And this is what she said.
Witches be like, sometimes I just want
to listen to music while pining away,
sulking, staring out a window. It's me.
I'm witches. Never fear, the Willow
lonely witch remix is here. So she made
a remix of that song Willow.
And it's weird because it just sounds so
similar. People are having a hard time
dissecting like how it's a remix, but
she calls it the witches remix or the
lonely witches remix. And then she also
says, it's me, I'm witches. So
She put crystal ball emoji in there?
Yeah.
Did you notice her handle?
Taylor Swift 13. Yeah. Oh, the 13.
Her lucky number, which again, in tarot
cards stands for death. So something.
Play rhino means?
[laughter]
I was like I was like, wait, what?
Man, [laughter] you're going too deep.
So this is the final clip we're going to
take a look at. This is from her song
Karma.
Interesting again, it seems like she's
singing about how karma is her friend.
But like as in if you do something bad
to her, it will come back and get the
other person. So again, it's like a
revenge kind of song.
[music]
So that was blatantly satanic. Yeah,
flipped upside down and goes into the
satanic She also has something here on
her waist. We'll probably put up on the
screen, but
like sun suns or something.
Symbols of the sun. Sun worship.
That's true. It's it's I think the sun
is actually used a lot in the
it's in the Jesuits logo, which is a
like an elite force of the Catholic
Church. It's an ancient thing. I want to
look at a song that she put out
recently. The lyrics of the song
would've, could've, should've. And it
says, all all I used to do was pray.
Would've, could've, should've if you
never looked my way.
I would've stayed on my knees and I
something sure would never would've
danced with the devil at 19. If you
never touched me, I would've gone along
with the righteous. If I never blushed,
then they could've never whispered about
this.
And if you never saved me from boredom,
I could've gone on as I was. But Lord,
you made me feel important and then you
tried to erase us.
Woah. That's some weird lyrics. Yeah. I
mean, I'm gathering that it's uh
obviously a sexual partner. Saying, hey,
I used to pray, I used to be this good
girl on my knees.
But when I turned 19 and met you, then
I'm dancing with the devil. If you
would've touched me, I could've just
continued being righteous, but you made
me feel so good. You got you saved me
from boredom. Yeah. And now it's the
Lord that wants to try and break us
apart. So she dated John Mayer at 19
when he was 30-something. Maybe she's
referring to John Mayer. It looks like
he she's writing about a male partner.
But the thing is like again, we see a
lot in her
media or what content she creates that
it's like a double-edged sword. Like
yeah, it seems like this on the surface,
but then
like if I have a breakup with a
boyfriend, I'm not going to talk about
like, oh man, I danced with the devil
and I used to pray and but hey, like
this devil
pulled me away and well, I would've been
with the righteous. Like I'm not going
to do that.
It's just like so much music is getting
more blatant about this.
Uh Demi Lovato, same thing, you know,
her
the last I don't know if it's her latest
album, but recently she had album where
she's
laying on a bed in the shape of a cross
and it's all the lyrics are about the
same thing. Like I used to be
holy and righteous and used to believe
in you, but now I'm doing what I want to
do type stuff. So there's also other
things that I didn't really touch on
today, which is that she's very pro
LGBTQ+. She's very much pro-abortion.
Um she even made a music video where
there's like a gay wedding and then
there's protesters who are like trailer
park people and they make the trailer
park people look really dirty and grimy
and dumb. And then the trailer park
people are protesting against the gay
wedding and they're just being put down
as like they're they're being written
off as like, man, you're just dumb and
like whatever. Like that's kind of how
they're portraying Christians. And
there's nothing even wrong with people
who live in trailer parks, you know, but
that's how they're trying to portray the
Christians as dumb and you don't know
what you're talking about. Let's have
gay weddings. So
you know, there's those things as well.
But I want to wrap it up with this verse
over here or two verses. First Timothy
2:3 and 4. This is good and pleases God
our savior, who wants everyone to be
saved and to understand the truth. And
John 3:16. So what is that truth that
God is talking about? For this is how
God loved the world. He gave his one and
only son that so that everyone who
believes in him will not perish, but
have eternal life.
I truly believe that God wants to save
Taylor Swift. I truly believe that he's
pursuing her every single day
relentlessly because he loves her so
much. He wants to see her in heaven.
And he is hurting and crying over her
lost soul that she, you know,
is doing all this demonic satanic stuff
in her performances.
And
you know, God God wants her back and
he's fighting for her. We don't want to
live. This world is a
testament of what it's like to do it our
own way and how it's full of pain,
misery, heartache. We don't want this
world anymore. We want a new world with
perfection in it.
And so
you know, that's why it says
[snorts]
he wants us to not willing that any
should perish, but that all should come
to repentance. We have to repent so that
we can have eternal life. And he's
long-suffering. That's why he hasn't
returned yet. He's He's waiting for
people to make that decision for him.
Mhm. It's a beautiful thing.
The Bible gives us some
sage advice.
And it's in 1 John chapter 2.
And the title, if you have chapter title
or
titles is do not love the world. It
says, "Do not love the world or the
things in the world.
If any man loves the world, the love of
the Father is not in him.
For all that is in the world, the lust
of the flesh, the lust of the eyes, and
the pride of life is not of the Father,
but is of the world.
And the world is passing away
and the lust of it, but he who does the
will of God abides forever." Mhm.
So, if you want your life to last, you
have to put it in God's hands. You have
to do the will of the Father because all
these things here
it's all going away. Yeah. It's only
temporary. So, live for God. Amen.
Well, everybody, that is our LED live
for today. Um again, we want to make a
statement that we're not here to bash
Taylor Swift. We truly believe that God
wants to save her, but we do want to
expose darkness.
Um so, if you want to be a light in the
world, you should buy our t-shirts.
That's a really good plug. Yeah.
[laughter] You can go to lightwear.shop
and buy these t-shirts that we're
wearing or I mean, there's so many other
designs out there where you can wear
your witness and tell the world about a
loving Jesus, loving savior who wants to
save us. Amen. Also, if you want to help
support this ministry, please go to
lls.tv/give
or patreon.com/littlelightstudios.
And we also have a podcast. If you want
to dive deeper into the Bible, uh in
this podcast, we seek to answer your
most challenging Bible questions. So,
look up Little Light Studios podcast
wherever you listen to your podcasts. We
are also coming out with a brand-new
YouTube channel called Little Light
Kids. If you want Bible-based
uh TV shows for your kids, check it out,
subscribe, support us cuz we're trying
to build up this new YouTube channel.
[music]
I think that's it for today. Give the
video a thumbs up.
video a thumbs up. Make sure you hit
subscribe. And we will see you in the
next one. Bye.
If you're looking for good, wholesome,
educational content [music] for your
children, subscribe to our new channel
Little Light Kids.
Hey, subscribe to Little Light Studios
en español. Vas a encontrar muchos
videos de Little Light Studios que están
traducidos en español y también
contenido exclusivamente para nuestra
audiencia latina. If you want to learn
in Spanish, a great way will be watching
our videos for practice.
[music]